so today I'm going to share some really
interesting information on kidney stones
I think it's actually groundbreaking
I've done a lot of videos on kidney
stones but I've never talked about this
one thing the thing or the trigger that
originates this kidney stone in the
first place I mean when you think about
it it's just so weird that people
develop stones in their kidney like
what's up with that and the pain from
kidney stones can be devastating I mean
just unbearable but this calcification
thing is happening in other parts of the
body too calcification of your joints as
an arthritis we get calcification or
plaquing in Our arteries teeth as tartar
we even can get calcification in our
eyes as in cataracts it can even happen
in the inner ear and create symptoms of
ringing in the ear tinnitus when someone
has Alzheimer's or even dementia they
found calcium deposits within the
synapses of the brain then you get
hardening of the arteries which causes
high blood pressure and even Strokes so
so there's a relationship with that and
even when you have gallstones there's
cholesterol there but there's also
calcium calcium deposits can also
accumulate in the breast tissue it can
also occur with MS and even developing
your lymph nodes as in tonsil stones so
what the heck is going on with this
calcium well to figure this problem out
I always like to go to Nature to see if
there's a similar thing going on and if
we look at nature okay especially coral
reefs for example that's a calcium
deposit formation also if you ever look
at like hot springs there's calcium
formations going on with that I mean
even if you look deep in the soil you'll
find Limestone right where does that
come from well we'll get into that and
even in the bottom of ships you have
these huge Barnacles those are calcium
formations and what do all these calcium
formations have in common microbes
microbes make these calcium formations
and when I did this deep dive into this
top I finally found the key article that
I've been looking for there was a study
on kidney stones that evaluated I think
it was 78 or 79 people and out of the 78
or 79 people with kidney stones they
found
97.2 percent of them
had tiny bacteria in the kidney stone
and these tiny bacteria okay they were
very very tiny they're like a hundred
times smaller than bacteria are called
nanobacteria Nano meaning very very
small and by the way this is a very
recent discovery or finding because of
our ability to view things with certain
types of microscopes in the past we
could never find these things but deep
inside these kidney stones there are
microbes and they're nanobacteria and it
just so happens that these nanobacteria
eat calcium and then form bone-like
Crystal structures and that is called
appetite but it's a completely different
definition of when you have an appetite
for food okay appetite is a type of
calcium phosphorus that is in bone okay
and these nanobacteria actually make
this type of calcium as an igloo type
structure to help them survive against
various stresses like
antibiotics antibiotics are a drug that
kills bacteria and one of the big side
effects of antibiotics is enhanced
microbial
biofilms and biofilms are these colonies
with microbes with these little calcium
Igloo type protective shells so every
time someone takes an antibiotic they
actually make the microbes survive
stronger because they adapt and they
actually enhance the formation of these
organisms and this is why the solution
is not to just take another antibiotic
to kill off these microbes and make the
environment very sterile because it just
makes things worse now some other
information if you didn't already know
this that actually will make sense is
that they've also found these small
microorganisms in the plaque in your
teeth in the plaque in your arteries in
the calcium deposits in your joints so
where you may have thought this problem
was just an excess amount of calcium
it's actually not this is not being
created because you have too much
calcium in the diet it's not being
created because you are taking too many
calcium supplements it has a lot more to
do with this microbe and what this
microbe is doing within its environment
so if we take a deeper look at these
nanobacteria there's a couple things
that you need to know about them they
form biofilms which are colonies that
bind together with calcium shells to
survive they're very resistant against
antibiotics in fact they get stronger
when you take an antibiotic they can
grow in different PHS in different
environments in different temperatures
and in different stresses in fact the
more you stress them the more they grow
the big complication of these microbes
in their shells is our own immune system
has a difficult time detecting them but
they do detect as a problem and there's
usually going to be some type of of
immune response that goes on for a long
period of time which means that your
body your own body's immune system
creates more inflammation and that's
where you get a lot of the complications
from the plaquing in your teeth you know
in your gums or plucking in the arteries
or plucking in your joints a lot of the
symptoms that you experience are coming
actually from your own immune system
trying to get rid of this deeper
infection now as a really interesting
side note one really good remedy to help
decrease these nanobacteria and decrease
biofilms is citrate where does citrate
come from lemons it's the citric acid or
the citrate in lemons which is kind of a
common remedy for kidney stones well now
we might know why because citrates help
to inhibit the formation of biofilms now
the mechanism of how this thing develops
is very similar to how H pylori creates
ulcers if you don't know about that
connection a lot of the ulcers that
people develop come from this bacteria
and it's sitting in your stomach now a
lot of people have H pylori but it's
asymptomatic there's no symptoms until
your environment changes in your stomach
where your pH becomes altered and maybe
your diet becomes off and then this
somewhat um neutral or somewhat friendly
H pylori shifts its relationship to
become a bit unfriendly and it starts to
develop problems in your stomach and of
course the treatment that they use for
this is antibiotics which have side
effects but the point is that the great
majority of the public has this microbe
in their body and it's not doing
anything it's not creating problems it's
kind of like a neutral type response I
mean the same thing you could say for
any microorganism when you start to take
antibiotics for example and you create
stress now we get an overgrowth of
fungus right because the bacteria was
there in the first place to keep the
fungus or candida in check antibiotics
only kill bacteria they don't kill
fungus or candida or Yeast so now you
get rid of this one thing which is the
protective thing now you get this
overgrowth on the other side candida
overgrowth or thrush there's much higher
risk of people getting these problems
like I'm talking about kidney stones but
some of these other problems too when
someone is obese when someone is a
diabetic when they have high blood
pressure when they have kidney problems
or kidney disease and when they're
immune compromised like an HIV or when
they take a lot of Prednisone so the way
that I can make sense out of this is
that someone might manifest kidney
stones if there's maybe a weakness
within the kidney from some past injury
versus another problem with these
nanobacteria in your arteries or maybe
you had damage in the eye and that's
where this problem develops or the
joints kind of similar to cancer where
cancer tends to spread in areas of
inflammation or weakness or old injury
now you might be thinking well how do we
kill off this microbe well first you
have to deal with the shell right the
problem with that is if you start to
destroy the shell you're going to
release a lot of these microbes into the
blood into the urine which can create
more problems and then these microbes
can then become like what's called
endotoxins and the problem with that is
they can create more infection in other
places in the body and this is why with
like lipotripsy where they they blast
the kidney stone right with the sound
wave
a person will have a greatly increased
risk of eating infection
afterwards and this is probably why they
give you an antibiotic to kill
everything that has been released into
the body so when you start to use
various even natural remedies to break
up these calcium shells you have to
realize what you're doing I'll give you
an example with Karen my wife she wanted
to take a remedy for biofilms right for
her sinus problems and so she took this
very powerful remedy and it definitely
worked it broke up all sorts of things
that then as a complication
she didn't look too good there was
something seriously going on with her
digestive system where she could not go
to the bathroom she had this huge knot
she couldn't eat she felt sick and this
went on for several days until as I was
researching this I found one of the side
effects when you start breaking up
biofilms is this problem called
cholestasis where you have this stagnant
bile that is just kind of jammed up in
the bile ducts so apparently when you
release the microbes they could do some
damage and they can even inhibit the
formation of bile which now we get this
thickened stuff that gets stuck in the
bile ducts and it can back up in the
liver and create all sorts of problems
including constipation so what we
quickly did is a remedy and I'm going to
recommend this if you decide to use some
type of biofilm even a natural remedy or
some chelation type remedy which is
called EDTA you're going to break up
these things I recommend before you do
that okay from personal experience
experience you want to take something
called Tut cup tatka is a type of bile
salt that will get the bile flowing
first so when you destroy these biofilms
and calcium shells it can be released
through the body okay so just make
mental note if you decide to do that and
you want to go really really slow with
any type of thing that you're going to
use to destroy the biofilms I would have
some activated charcoal on the side and
I would take that as needed because
activated charcoal can help absorb a lot
of the toxic material that you are
breaking up as it's coming out through
the body however doing that requires a
little more information and a lot more
preparation so I'm going to give you a
different approach to this okay that's a
little more streamlined less
complications and so the first thing I
would highly recommend you do which is
going to help you prevent any more
kidney stones okay it's probably the
best thing you can do is to start
drinking more fluid like 2.5 leaders
every single day that way these Stones
cannot form okay because the stones
always form in a super concentrated
urine so if you're drinking enough fluid
they can't form so right there it'll
probably prevent you from having any
kidney sounds all right number two I
would start taking calcium citrates okay
plus lemons I would probably do two or
three or four ounces of lemon a day or
two or three or four lemons a day in
your water okay I would use that and I
would also on top of that use potassium
citrate you can find that in a lot of
electrolyte powders but the potassium
citrate is a really good anti-biofilm
and it can help reduce the risk of
kidney stones the next thing I would do
is I would take probably one of the most
powerful natural antibiotics okay that
would be garlic and I would take the
garlic in a freeze-dried form if I can
get it however other forms are going to
be fine but freeze-dried garlic would be
a nice natural antibiotic that is
selected to those bacteria but won't
create any damage to your cells now what
you're doing is you're taking something
like an antibiotic and without any risk
factor of developing antibiotic
resistance because it's natural and
you're creating an environment where
these microbes can't continue to exist
optimize the environment around these
microbes okay so over time these
biofilms and nanobacteria can go away
not just in your kidneys but in the
heart in the eyes and the joints all
over kidney stones are just the tip of
the iceberg that is the symptom of an
unhealthy environment probably because
of bad eating habits or whatever so what
I mean by cleaning up the environment is
getting on a healthy ketogenic diet with
intermittent fasting I would recommend
to build up your microbiome there are
certain microbes that can greatly help
prevent these bowel films and of course
doing whatever you can to decrease
stress and that means stress for the
microbes too so really limit the times
you take antibiotics or take drugs or
expose yourself to chemicals that can
cause these microbes to then adapt and
then become stronger now I think it's
appropriate to watch this next video
probably one of my most important videos
on kidney stones right here check it out